where everybody's just sort of like like
just realizing everything is just kind
of ridiculous like the whole thing's
ridiculous nobody's really 100 right
nobody's 100 wrong it's all sort of
[__] silly oh man it's stupid and
it's it's designed to fail
that's our world yes wow that turned
dark we're designed to fail yes and I
blame God
and not a lot of people don't do you
believe in God are you are you religious
uh I was and then I wasn't and now I am
again what happened
uh
uh I got past organized religion
and I was like this this is always them
trying to explain what they didn't
understand so they don't understand it
doesn't just because they don't
understand it and they use it in the
wrong way it doesn't mean that it's not
there so I'm trying to have my own like
uh cult
is that really a scratch on your
forehead from a child or is that a Mark
that was a yeah it was a ritual
um
no I'm just I'm kind of just having my
own
I'm just kind of having my own thing all
right you know I like whatever my idea
of it isn't any any better than your
idea isn't any more right or wrong and
like
um what's your idea I want to hear your
idea my idea I just think that it's
it's like uh
the Earth is more like his like
just like sort of an artist right and
then he just designed these things
to [__] with each other for like his own
entertainment you know what I mean like
you need God as a comedian
no it doesn't know it's not always fun I
don't think
I don't think he cares
that's my thing I don't think that he
cares what happens to you if he cares he
wouldn't make serial killers which he
does
he does make Syracuse and I'm sick of
him
pawning that off on the devil because he
also created the devil that is also his
creation so shouldn't he just handle
that
like why doesn't he just handle that
[__] why do we have to deal with it why
is there this big [__] test
well it doesn't make any [__] sense
the whole thing is [__] stupid the
whole thing is [__] if you just look
at animals what do animals do nothing
and then you look how some are just out
there with teeth like mine running next
to these monsters and they get ripped
apart and eaten alive and he made that
too
so like he's he's not you know I don't
think he's like the most you know chill
dude right you've become so spiritual
since the last time we we talked
I was expecting that take but it's a
beautiful take you should open up the
Church of Burr but the Church of Burr no
I don't understand why he drops you in
this Cesspool and then [__] happens to
you and then the end of your life he's
yelling at you like what the [__] was
that what the [__] was that was what you
made
it was what the [__] you made and I ran
into all those [__] [__]
I don't want to be like this you think
I'm gonna be a [__] angry lunatic
well I think you know what's funny maybe
if you tried a little harder with some
of the people in my life when you made
them
you lazy [__] instead of [__] working
six days and putting your feet up and
that's it and let the thing just go
where it's gonna go
and then it's my responsibility this
little [__] spec on this [__]
planet go [__] yourself
I'm not really saying it to him I'm
saying it to like all organized
religions I don't want to I don't want
to so you believe in a [__] [__]
I believe that God is everything all
right I'm with you and he's also a [__]
can we put that in the uh in the liner
in the thumbnail
we found God he's a [__]
[Laughter]
I do believe that the only Power that
you do have is to try to be nice to
people
that's really at the end of it that's
all you have even wow that is a great
ending to that rant yeah so be nice I
don't have to go down to his level
this is where the ego comes in I put
myself above God and then I start my
cult but I think we're pretty similar in
our beliefs I'm not I've kind of moved
away from organized religion and because
organized religion is disorganized it's
just this group of people it's people as
soon as you get in organized religion
it's not about God it's not about a
power greater than us it's about this
building that they've built and the
rules that they put in place so that you
follow these buildings and every
building has different rules but what we
can all agree on is there is a power
greater than what we can see and feel
right now I mean and you just said it
you know looking and it's sitting on
your back porch looking at those
beautiful Creations in the pool these
are yeah these were created
from something bigger than we can even
100 we can even articulate so I think
the key to life in my in my opinion is
to be nice which is putting it very
simply but it's considered weak
that's how [__] up we are really was
Mother Teresa week
I heard she was a [__]
I
funny t-shirt the other day that sounded
like remember the ten thousand dollar
pyramid where they would be giving out
Clues yeah it said God's guns and guts
and it just felt like ten thousand
dollar pyramid you know with the clock
taken down yeah Gods guns guts it's like
uh the three things that ruin a peaceful
Society right
and now they're gonna be a bunch of gun
nuts going like oh you remember World
War II I do how did it start
there you go yeah there you go but but
what I'm saying is we need to be there
for other human beings and we need to be
nice and we need to be fearful and
respectful of a power greater than we
can describe and and know that it's
bigger than us I don't need that
motivation that's what always bugged me
but yeah but you are and he's [__]
mad at you I'm not saying it's a guy as
a Jew I'm not 100 a woman
it's a hundred percent a woman because
God takes no responsibility for his
actions
I'll read the comments
[Laughter]
[Music]